we spend a lot of time looking at the
basic theory of prototyping you know
enough by now to know these things are
only useful if you actually build them
so let's get started on that
the fundamental idea behind prototypes
is that you're making the fastest
version of a thing that can get you the
information you need from the people you
need it from to that end it's useful to
think about what the fastest possible
prototyping method would be since that's
what you'll want for your first few
prototypes
we'll be showing you two options either
of which work for your own app or our
example app
behind this curtain is your best friend
the tool that will allow you to
prototype and pivot faster than any
other tool get ready
yeah look at that
sketching your prototypes simply on
paper is the single best way to work on
prototypes when you're starting a
project from scratch and allows you to
change course very easily
you can redo parts of your designs
during user testing in order to clarify
things that are being called out as
confusing
these paper prototypes are going to be
super low fidelity but they will give
users enough of an idea of your app that
their feedback will tell you if you're
going in the right direction
there's one other method of fast
prototyping and it's behind this other
curtain
prepare to be amazed
yeah that's a printer
when you've gone through the work of
making mocks for an app you can build a
simple paper prototype by printing out
these mocks if you have mocks from the
product design course this route could
be for you
both methods will work for us here and
they will both lead to great user
feedback